I'm Christopher Hine I want to talk to
you guys a little bit about what's been
going on with the YouTube channel here
and what's going on with us here at the
dojo and Fresno so right now Fresno has
a shelter-in-place order so the students
can't come into the dojo so if you
notice we I've been posting a whole lot
of videos lately it's because I'm using
that as a stopgap so my students still
have some material to work on and look
at everyday in the dojo I told the
students during this time that we need
to be working on the academic aspects of
Aikido instead of the physical aspect so
can't get into train you might not have
a partner to train with at home and you
can do exercise on your own but it's
hard to do the real intense part of
Aikido training so what what I'm doing
is having us work on the academic aspect
so understanding better how I key to
work systematically and what it's there
to do so I've been putting out videos
now six to seven days a week for the
last month which has been great and I'm
glad there's been some nice responses to
that but I'm gonna slowly start weaning
these videos off we're gonna go to three
videos a week and then two and then
probably one video a week because I need
to spend most of my time right now on
our virtual dojo so we have an online
virtual dojo so there's a lot of stuff
that has to get written for that and
organized for that stuff so that's what
I'm gonna be spending a majority of my
time if you're interested in the virtual
dojo I will put some links in this to
kind of help you figure that out it's
not up for the public right now it's
just my students are using it but I'm
trying to streamline it so if you're
coming from the outside you'd be able to
get in there so if you're interested in
that you can send me a message or check
out the links below and I'll mention a
little bit about what the virtual dojo
is but we're not gonna totally disappear
I'm just petering it down a little bit
because I need to focus more of my time
right now on the virtual dojo and my
dojo so we're gonna just make fewer
videos for YouTube hopefully we'll stick
it at least one a week for awhile but
we're gonna start streamlining it down
and if you're interested in this
approach then you can check out some of
my other stuff and I'm gonna make more
and more material available for students
outside the dojo and also we have a
podcast I can't discuss so if you're
interested in hearing what we're talking
about that's a good way to find us so
thanks for your patronage on here I
appreciate it and stay tuned we're gonna
keep presenting material it's just gonna
slow down a little bit so don't freak
out just putting a little energy in in a
few other places I'm justifying and
thanks for all your attention I
appreciate it